man spent many a moon in the front
office of the green bay packers
and he joins us here now on the rich
eisen show
uh to give us his perspective you can
catch
his sport his business of sports podcast
and his sunday seven newsletter free to
your email every sunday morning at
andrewbrandt.com
andrew brandt here on the rich eisen
show how you been sir
i mean well my friend it's good to be
with you and uh
you know whenever we talk about aaron i
think i want to give some perspective 15
years ago
you know we take aaron in the first
round everyone hated it the crowd below
us
at lambeau field booged so hard it shook
our souls
that we took aaron rodgers and then it
was three years rich
you know it was three years of managing
these relationships where i'm dealing
with brett farves camp
pretty much every week or so you know
andrew do you know what it's like to
come into work every day and
sit with your replacement it's not fun
it's no fun and then aaron's camp would
be
is he ever going to play like that's
never going to retire so is he ever
going to play there what are you going
to do
and you just try to be professional and
tactful and understanding but you don't
have the answers and if you did
you don't want to give the answers
because you want to main maintain
flexibility as an organization
to when you make the move and turn the
keys over to aaron rodgers
so that's what happened now you fast
forward 15 years they've done the same
thing again
the day they drafted jordan love i hope
they're ready to manage this
forget about on the field are they ready
to manage this
and this is what i mean about management
you're gonna have
agents and hurt feelings and wanting
answers
all the time like all the time
and i don't know if they've managed it
well because aaron was a good soldier
wasn't you know brett called us
seconds after the pick and he was livid
but aaron you know
said all the right things but you could
tell after the championship game
he was kind of like you know what are we
doing here
and i think the packers all along in my
mind i don't know inside knowledge on
this
was to move to jordan love in 2022 and i
get the
sense that aaron's like well what am i
doing here you know
i'm you want me to be a placeholder
while i'm the mvp of the league
so i think that the control of the
timeline is what's at issue here well
then there's a couple of questions of
what you just said uh
i guess in a preamble to start our
conversation here yeah andrew
um is that there are some differences
one that i know and one that i'm
wondering about let's start with the one
that i'm wondering about did you guys
give favre a heads up that you were
gonna
take aaron rodgers or you couldn't
really do that because you didn't expect
him to fall down at 24 unless you
watched
mike majo's preview on nfl total access
days before the draft where he nailed it
so did did you give farve a heads up
before making the pick
or no we did not we did not and as you
said two things happened that night
number one
all the players we had rated as first
round grades except one
were taken and the one that was still on
the board
was not taken by all these teams that
had told him to his face
if he was there they'd take him so
we had a lot of conversation in those
combustible moments before
the pick and the coaches are crazy like
why would we do that he's not going to
help us this year maybe not next year
maybe never
and ted thompson bless his heart looked
at me and everyone else and said well
andrew what do we always say
trust the board trust the board
and i said ted you know brett's going to
be upset fans are going to be upset
aaron's going to be upset coming to a
cold place where he's not going to play
and he said i don't care you know we
trust the board here
and he had that fortitude to do that so
no
brett did not find out to the rest of us
and like i said he called the coach
within seconds and bus cook called me
within seconds
and what happened you know bus is like
what the f
what are we doing you want to replace
them
and i just said you know we have to
prepare for the future this you know the
organizations have to evolve
at some point brett is going to retire
there obviously been rumors up to that
point
we have to be prepared and then as i
said it was the cavalcade over years
of you know it's not great walking into
work every day sitting with your
replacement that's so fun and i guess
that i get
that but we've got to prepare as an
organization
and so what was farv's uh commentary
about
he called uh he called the coach writer
he called mccarthy
right away no which was the last year of
mike sherman
sherman and uh he did call and
you know i think those conversations
were ongoing and
that's one way to put it
ongoing i love it well ongoing until
three years later
he retires we turn the team over to
aaron
and as i suspected gosh i wish i you
know
he'd get the itch and he did of course
and there was that fateful day i think
it was june 20th
19 2008 mike mccarthy said three words
that no player wants to hear
and he said it to a hall of famer that
was the face of the franchise for 20
years he said
we've moved on and when i heard
you know when i saw bus and brett hear
those words it was almost like
this is the most poignant words ever
heard he said
i'm sorry we've moved on and we were not
going to take the keys from aaron and
give them back to brett
that's just not what we're going to do
andrew brown of course the
divorce yeah yeah andrew brandt of uh
sports illustrated former packers
executive
right here on the rich eisen show and
one thing though
as we're strolling down memory lane here
about the remarkable similarities
between the time that you were there
when you drafted aaron rodgers along
with ted thompson
uh and favre was in the building and now
rogers is in the role of farve and
jordan love is in the role of rogers and
you said you got calls from
farv's representative and bus cooks and
what gives and you got a call from
rogers representative
saying what gives the difference is now
is
jordan love and aaron rodgers are
represented by the same agent
and david dunn so what do you think the
david dunn conversations with brian
kudikunst
or like right about now andrew
what do you think well as a former agent
you know if you look at it from a 360
degree view
the best scenario for the agent is
probably having
aaron running one team and jordan
running the packers
you know because they need to have two
starting quarterbacks in a situation
where you can only have one
i don't know you know the whole thing to
me rich
is people talk about money and upgrading
past my homes and doing future
guarantees in the country
like you don't even get to the money the
money's easy that's what i did for 10
years we can figure that out
but you don't get to the money until you
figure out what is the problem here
and what concerns me the most this whole
thing is that lefleur
gouda kunst and murphy reportedly
have been out there and sat in la and
sat in front of aaron
and tried to address the grievances and
here we are
you know people ask what would i do of
course i'd do the same thing i'd get in
front of them close the doors lock the
bathrooms what's the problem how would
we fix it
but it sounds like that's happened
so now where do you go and ultimately
it's up to earn i mean they're not
trading them
for they're not trading they're not
trading them
they may trade them in 2022 but they're
not trading them in 2021
so then the ball is going to be in
aaron's court so
the options are to hold out and then get
through training camp and
you know i mean this conversation is
about taking place about a half an hour
before we're expecting to hear from
jordan love
you know already bak tiari and devonte
adams have answered the question lafleur
is coming up with different ways to say
i don't have an answer where we'd love
to have him back i'm only going to coach
the guys that i'm here i'm like he's
going to
it's june 7th and 8th now and we're
running out of that time 9th
what's that going to be like july you
know august 9th
september 9th you know we just saw
jordan love struggle in his
you know uh mini camp drills it
invariably he would struggle
week one against the saints my lord so
really like that's the way this is going
to play out you think
andrew yeah i mean you know my saying
deadlines for action
rights was not a deadline in my mind
there's no deadline to mini camp
i mean you know they can find them 90
000 they probably won't in my opinion
then you get to training camp they have
to find them according to cba they can't
rescind those fines
they're 50 000 a day but i don't think
training camps a deadline either i think
like you just intimated
deep into training camp there'll be some
kind of deadline
but again aaron's
yeah you know once you get past holdouts
rich what are the two there are two
options
playing for the packers or not playing
football
and i know aaron doesn't
want to retire i think if he retires it
would be a total
feeling like he can't participate in
this organization anymore
somewhere along the way there's been a
breach of trust between the front office
and aaron
and i don't know what it is it's way
beyond jordan love and calling him
draft room and all that that that's not
it i just think there's
he doesn't have someone in that front
office that he feels he can
trust and something has breached that
relationship
so there's no fix andrew i mean there's
no that's that that's the
the ultimate uh unless aaron gets over
for the lack of better phrase whatever
breach has occurred
that's basically what you're saying to
me right here on this wednesday of
mandatory mini camp that he did not show
up at that's essentially
it yeah and and i'm saying having been
in that chair for 10 years the packers
for an office chair
i get what they're trying to do they're
trying to have their cake and eat it too
they're trying to have the mvp
get them to another championship games
super bowl in 2021
and then move on and give love a real
opportunity to be a backup this year and
i get it
but aaron's sitting there saying i'm not
down with that of course not you know
you want me to be a placeholder
while i'm the mvp of the league
so to me it's like a battle for you know
aaron's probably saying and maybe dave
dunn is saying
let's just do this now you know let's do
it now
why wait why wait a year because the
packers are like we don't we do want to
wait a year we want aaron rodgers
level of talent and then maximize trade
value in march
so then i guess the last question for
you andrew is is is did
did they just meet aaron rodgers i mean
you know what i mean like it's
in all honesty you know uh uh gouda
kunst has been there since what 97
he had a front row seat to everything
that you're kind of talking about right
now
all right and mark murphy's been there
forever and a day he's had a front row
seat
did they just meet the guy i mean like
you know what do you expect like he he
knows when he's being managed
he knows 2022 is the time he gave him a
freebie in 2020.
he's not going to give him a freebie in
2021 he's already said that
like what do you expect
that's a great question and you know
aaron as well as i do what you just
described
he can he can put people as he calls it
on blast sometimes
and listen ted thompson
was an elite evaluator but he was not a
communicator and he said to me
and john schneider and rich mckenzie and
john dorsey
you guys do that and i don't know if
brian
has that or has it's trying to do it
himself
you know i'm sure brian's an elite
evaluator as well and and is he
is he doing the communication is he
having someone else do that are they
getting stilted between
him and murphy and russ ball i mean it
just sounds like
exactly what you said like what are they
missing with aaron and why are these
meetings in la
not advancing the ball at all so i'm
left scratching my head as you are
andrew thanks for the time the business
sports podcast host the mmqb columnist
and also get his sunday seven newsletter
free delivered to your email every
sunday morning you sign up but
andrew.brandt
dashbrandtbrandt.com let's continue this
conversation
thanks for the call sir thanks rich talk
soon you bet that's andrew brandt follow
him on twitter at andrew brandt i do
as well hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here